us kids und herzlich willkommen zu einem
kleinen infoblock ja es passieren
in letzter zeit viele seltsame dinge
gestern kamen video das war abends
wieder runter war weg warum weiß nicht
keine piraten auf jeden fall mache ich
jetzt noch mal ein video wo garantiert
nichts zu beanstanden ist dass ich dann
auch oben lassen kann war möchte ich
nochmal für alle die es gestern
vielleicht nicht mitbekommen haben sagen
dass demnächst aufnahmen mit konkreter
kommen werden haben uns abgesprochen
werden demnächst zusammen aufnehmen
ich glaube sowohl auf seinem kinn alter
auf meinem ich weiß das nicht ganz genau
ja ich habe dann einfach mal so
angeschrieben und johann haben wir uns
irgendwie geeinigt so kommt einfach so
einfach ein bisschen absprache und
bisher hat mich sogar angeschrieben
erzählt es jetzt einfach noch mal also
ich hab mir gestern ja schon mal so ein
video gemacht das möchte ich aber
unternehmen weil dominate mafia und
yakuza und ganz schöne sache ich mag es
gar nicht genau erzählen weil ich dann
wahrscheinlich ab genug wird ich hoffe
es jetzt keiner meiner tür nämlich jetzt
gleich umbringen würden also auf jeden
fall ist es so dass wie gesagt diese
videos kommen werden und sorry für alle
das ich das nochmal erzähle für alle die
das gestern schon gesehen haben tut mir
leid aber heute ist wieder so ein
krasser tag leute lasst mich kurz mal
erzählen was heute bei mir ansteht
also ich habe erstmal der letzten nacht
wie immer viel zu wenig geschlafen heißt
bei mir so unter sieben stunden also ich
sag immer unter sieben stunden das
reicht mir einfach nicht weil es viele
schlafen sechs stunden sind
ausgeschlafen manche vielleicht sogar 5
ihr könnt ihr mal in die kommentare
schreiben
wie lange er so schlaf aber mir ist es
so wenn ich weniger als sieben stunden
schlaf dann
milito nicht gut auf jeden fall muss ich
dann heute morgen aufstehen und ja so
ist es sowieso ist jeden mittwoch bei
mir bei mir natürlich erzähle ich
erstmal wie sie mal wie es aussieht
zwar ist es so ich stehe auch zu wenig
geschlafen
die viel zu spät auf fast verpönt dann
irgendwie power küche wenn die küche
machen ein bisschen kaffee machen das
sind frühstück in der regel immer so
müsst ihr mit ein bisschen proteinpulver
ein bisschen licht so wie ich das in
letzter zeit machen und dann halt in die
uni und geht um 10 los
dann hatte ich heute morgen erst mal
spanisch eineinhalb stunden
dann habe ich eineinhalb stunden micro
als eine stunde mikroökonomie also zur
wirtschaftswissenschaften danach dann
habe ich zweieinhalb stunden das kommt
jetzt gleich deswegen habe ich auch
nicht so viel zeit
statistik launig und dann nochmal
wirtschaftsmacht also fünf stunden und
nochmals voll kranke von zehn uhr
morgens bis 19 uhr immer vorlesung mit
vox und deswegen habe ich halt mittwoch
und versiert zum video zu machen aber
ich muss jetzt unbedingt das noch mal
klarstellen was da gestern los war und
zwar ja es gab danach verschwörungen
gegen mich also deswegen sage ich
einfach so werden aufnahmen kommen mit
luca haben uns da abgesprochen wir beide
und ihr wisst ja also luca ist ein guter
kollege von max und maxi mein bruder ich
kenne luca auch aus dem urlaub weil
dieses nichtwissen max und luca und ich
fahren ja immer zusammen in urlaub nach
sylt jeden sommer und ja da können wir
uns einfach ich kenn luca jetzt auch
schon 23 jahre oder so und eigentlich
seltsam ist eigentlich wir bisher nicht
nicht so viel aufgenommen haben und ja
jetzt kommt halt dazu gab es mal
abgesprochen und sogar kleiner pisser
also zu mir hey du kleiner pisser also
kleiner pisser das auch niemand sommers
gemacht so war das glaubt mir wirklich
doch genau so nicht anders na ja auf
jeden fall wollte ich euch diese info
nochmal bringen und noch entschuldigen
mich entschuldigen dafür dass gestern
das video runter genommen werden musste
ich hoffe es war nicht allzu tragisch
auf jeden fall mache jetzt nochmal den
aufruf erstmal sorry dafür wenn ich
jetzt dinge doppelt zahlen die gestern
schon gehört habt danke dafür dass euch
das video trotzdem angeschaut habt ich
musste noch mal machen für alle die das
video gestern nicht sehen konnten 2000
habe ich bestimmt nicht gesehen oder so
keine ahnung weil sich ja nicht jeden
fall jetzt noch mal alle infos in einem
video kommt mir etwas video darf dann
nach oben bleiben lasten daumen nach
oben da wenn ihr lust drauf habt dass
ich mit luca aufnehme und euch auf die
videos freude die er demnächst kommen
werden auf verschiedenen channels und
natürlich auch wenn ihr
ja wenn ihr was eigentlich wenn ihr
genug schlaf klassenleiter wenn ihr
genug schlaf den 8 und wenn nicht genug
schlaf dann schreibt in die kommentare
nein ich schlafe immer nur 380 standen
das war das letzte video aller zeiten
egal macht's gut rein und wir sind so
ein bisschen video wieder